serious fighting around lissa chask has
been raging for more than a week over
the last 24 hours kremlin-backed
separatists insist they have encircled
the city a claim now backed by russia's
defence minister
the sixth kazakh regiment named after
ottoman platop together with our
fighting friend our fighters liberated
the city of lizzie chang's ahmed is
power cossacks are power together we are
power
but ukraine says the city is still under
its control and it's inflicting losses
on the advancing troops al jazeera can't
independently confirm either claim
in and around the nest the occupiers are
concentrating their main efforts on
securing positions in the cities of
lesser chunks and vert na kamenka their
attempted offensive actions near
balaguerevka had no success and they
were forced into retreat if lisa chance
were to fall to the russians
strategically it would be hugely
significant it would essentially mean
mosul controls luhansk and neighbouring
donetsk the two provinces which make up
the donbass and russia has concentrated
its military efforts there since pulling
back from the capital kyiv at the start
of the war in the russian city of
belgarrod 40 kilometers across the
ukrainian border
the mayor reported a series of
explosions overnight which hit a
residential area killing at least four
some russian politicians are demanding
ukraine pay a severe price for the
attack
and the ousted mayor of melatopal who
was replaced with a kremlin appointee
claims there has been a successful
attack on a russian base in the occupied
city
today the armed forces of ukraine took
out of action one of them at three
o'clock and five o'clock there were over
30 strikes exclusively on a military
base russian fascists are trying to
evacuate
any and damage military gear but there
is none left the situation enlisted
chance will be the one worrying the
ukrainian leadership most of all
losing that would be strategically
significant and they say the situation
will become much clearer in the next 24
hours and alan fisher is live for us now
in the ukrainian capital kiev allen as
you mentioned they're rapid advances by
the russians in the east and we've also
heard reports of shelling in the
ukrainian city of slovyansk
and slavian isn't very far away from
this aching
and that is what's deeply worrying
certainly in the last couple of hours
we've heard from the mayor there he said
there has been a sustained barrage of
russian rockets
that has happened over the last few
hours he's saying it's the worst assault
that he's seen since the start of the
war there are multiple fires raging
across the city that they're trying to
put out at least 15 according to his
calculations the number of people have
been killed six dead at least 15 injured
so it's clear that this is going to be
the new front line it all fits in with
the russian attempts to try and control
the entire donbass region that of course
was the region that wanted to be
separate from ukraine it was one of the
reasons that the russians said they were
invading was to give these people
autonomy to give them support for their
independence movement from ukraine it
has been at the center of their military
strategy since they decided to pull out
of kiev when they realized they weren't
going to take the capital as quickly as
they thought if at all and so they
decided to concentrate almost entirely
in the donbass region certainly across
the east and parts of the south we're
hearing reports of a lot more missiles
being fired the ukrainian
military saying that there has been
almost a doubling in the number of
rocket attacks just in the last week
alone and the word from many mayors in
cities across that region to people is
to please take care and when the alerts
and the alarms go off to head to the
shelters that is the way they say most
people will be able to keep themselves
safe alan fisher and kiev thank you